[Music]
welcome to this short specialty course
on gdpr and email marketing my name is
Matt Bailey
I am the email marketing and search
marketing course advisor at simply
learned I'll be presenting an overview
of the changes that email marketers need
to know about dealing with GDP our GDP
our or the general data protection
regulation is now in effect this governs
any data activities on all European
citizens so regardless of where your
business is located if you collect store
or utilize data from citizens of the EU
then you are subject to these legal
requirements the purpose of this
legislation is to create consistent and
enforceable requirements to protect the
right of any EU citizen to the privacy
and security of their personal data to
make this clear gdpr applies to any
business located in the u or outside of
the EU if you have any data on EU
citizens or if you email anyone within
the EU even if you are in a country
outside of any European Union countries
this still applies to you this applies
to anyone who collects data such as
subscriber data records organizes or
stores any of that data and performs any
operations on that data this is the most
extensive regulation on data privacy to
date however it will certainly not be
the last as more data is collected and
maintained on people companies have to
be responsible and accountable for that
data this is the goal of that
legislation now let's cover the
implications of GDP are for marketing in
general
first of all any user has the right to
request their data from any company that
keeps or maintains records as an
organization who maintains this data
you'll need to have a clear process for
users to request their data so
a form or automated process to download
in addition there should be a mechanism
to clearly confirm the identity of the
individual requesting the records a
company may not modify the information
or delete the information unless
deletion is specifically requested by
the user companies have one month to
fully comply with the right to request
and the information must be delivered in
a readable and portable format this
enables individuals to take their data
and move to another account or to simply
review all of the information a company
has in their records to protect the
company and the user it is recommended
that the entire right to request process
is documented and noted from the request
to the processing to the delivery as I
mentioned before this regulation applies
to anyone who collects keeps or
processes data this has an extensive
reach as something as simple as
segmenting a mailing list can be
considered processing of data for
example if you segment your list based
on the location of your subscribers then
you have processed their personal data
in addition if you use the data to
determine a relevant offer based on
their interests that is considered to be
processing of personal data as well this
applies to both a company that collects
and uses email data and to their
third-party provider such as an email
service provider this is considered a
shared responsibility as companies
develop the data acquisition mechanisms
and then use them for marketing and the
email service provider stores and
provides processing tools for those
companies in the right to request users
have the right to request their data but
in addition users had the right to know
about the purposes of the data
processing or the activities that a
company performs with their data for
example what data was used to segment
a target advertisement to them and how
is there data being used for
personalization of content this includes
the categories of personal data and the
existence of automated decision-making
including profiling this is very
extensive and companies will have to be
upfront with how they will use personal
data in addition companies will also
have to disclose relationships with
third-party providers that will have
access to the data or store the data
this includes the use of a CRM customer
relationship marketing database an
analytics provider or an email service
provider if a company is performing
targeted advertising based on personal
data then all advertiser relationships
will have to be disclosed
along with noting the data that is being
shared as mentioned before users have
the right to not only request the
personal data a company has on them the
data must be available in a portable
commonly used machine readable format
now this has typically been carried out
in PDF Excel or comma delimited formats
the user has the right to take this
portable information to another company
another right that greatly affects
marketers and companies is the right to
be forgotten or the right to erasure any
user can request that any and all data
be erased this can happen when the
personal data is no longer needed for
the original purpose also individuals
can withdraw consent for any data
processing this action has to be taken
without delay according to the
regulation the only exceptions to this
are reasons of public interest public
health and any scientific or historical
research this does not apply to
marketing and it is a stretch for any
company to use this as a defense when
performing marketing operations now
let's look specifically and how gdpr
relates to email marketing
the first issue that affects email
marketing is the opt-in process for
subscribing to marketing communications
the term used in the regulation is
unambiguous consent this is also
referred to as express consent this
means that the user must make an
unmistakeable action to opt-in this also
means that there is a clear statement of
the purpose or agreement of how the data
will be used if you are using checkboxes
they are not to be pre checked
pre checked boxes are not considered to
be expressed consent the goal is to
provide the user with clear terms and a
proof of consent by completing the form
there should be an unambiguous exchange
of user information in exchange for the
opt-in marketers will need to review all
of their existing forms and landing
pages to make sure that there are no pre
checked check boxes and that the terms
of the opt-in are clearly shown in this
example you can see that there are no
check boxes and that is fine this while
simple is an example of express consent
there is a clear statement of what the
company will do with the information
subscribe to our newsletters and by
completing the form the user will have
clearly opted into the agreement now
while a double opt-in function is not a
requirement for verification of consent
most email marketers are recommending
this as a quality assurance measure for
companies this may also be helpful as
further legislation is created to
protect consumers from unwanted
marketing communications this is an
example of the double opt-in after the
opt-in the user receives an email to
verify that the correct address is used
and the user clicks the link to verify
the address and verify the opt-in while
it is not required it will certainly add
another layer of consent verification
for marketing activity
the second issue is the opt-in form and
there must be separate opt-ins for each
separate offer for example if your users
must accept the Terms of Service the
Terms of Service cannot include
receiving marketing communications each
agreement must be separate as a
practical application of this if you
offer a white paper or a research
document to download with a registration
then opting into a newsletter cannot be
part of that registration it must be
offered separately this practice is
called bundling consent to receive
marketing communications must be given
separately
it cannot be bundled together with a
white paper download a webinar
registration or even a contact form here
is a great illustration of what not to
do as you can see here I was unable to
complete a transaction on this website
as I first had to agree to the terms and
conditions however the first point in
the Terms & Conditions statement is an
agreement to receive marketing offers
and communications this is not compliant
by any means as a user cannot purchase
from this website without opting into
marketing communications the third major
point is not only having opt-in consent
but for companies to have proof of that
consent this is where using a third
party email service provider enables a
clear record of consent important data
points to prove consent include the
subscribers name the date of consent the
subscription date what they agreed to
how they consented whether by a website
forum or checkbox on a checkout form if
that subscriber has unsubscribed then a
record of the withdrawn consent must
also be provable
as you can see from this screenshot of
an email service provider the status of
the subscriber the source of the octant
the date of the opt-in are all part of
the reporting and subscriber record
clear consent terms must be presented if
you are sending the same newsletter to
everyone without any processing or
segmenting of lists then the only terms
are to receive the newsletter if you are
processing the list to determine
personalized or regionalised offers or
segmenting by any user data points then
that processing must be disclosed for
example if you operate a contest on your
website and to enter a user provided
their email address then that is the
only way that you can use that data for
the contest you cannot then add that
user to marketing communications or a
newsletter list the reason is is that if
the original terms were only for a
contest then those were the agreed-upon
terms between you the company and that
user for their data to be used there
must be a clear and easy unsubscribe
process a user must be able to
unsubscribe with minimal this means that
a fee cannot be charged to remove a
subscriber the unsubscribe process must
be limited it cannot be a multi-page
process or ask for any information
beyond confirming the email address if
there is an account the user does not
have to login to unsubscribe finally
re-engagement emails well this is a
popular technique used by marketers in
other parts of the world it should not
be used in the EU companies are not
allowed to contact a user if they have
unsubscribed from communications one
company Flybe was fined seventy thousand
pounds for deliberately emailing
unsubscribed users this becomes a
vitally important issue for companies
that utilize re-engagement emails you
will have to verify the recipients
location prior to sending those emails
so what are the actions that email
marketers have to take in the light of
these ray
Galatians the first step is to audit
your current list you'll need to ensure
that your existing list of subscribers
was gathered in compliance with gdpr
requirements you don't always need to
get reconsent if you can already show
consent your current list must show a
clear and affirmative opt-in action and
this must be provable either with an
existing form or a screenshot of the
past form this consent must also be
recorded along with the terms of the
agreement so what does that mean
here are three essential questions to
ask about your current email lists 1 did
they opt-in to your list and can you
prove it the implication here is that if
you have email lists where users have
not explicitly opted in but you gather
those emails from other sources list
brokers websites purchase lists or other
means then there is no explicit consent
to on your past subscriber forms did you
clearly state what the subscriber is
agreeing to what they will receive and
how you will use their data 3 can
subscribers unsubscribe as easily as
they subscribe this means that you
cannot have an unsubscription mechanism
such as requiring a user to reply with
unsubscribe in the email subject line or
call a phone number or any other means
besides a quick one-page unsubscribe
form if you can show a proof of consent
along with the date and time of the
opt-in the source of the opt-in such as
a webform a campaign landing page form
or an API form from another website such
as Facebook and have a screenshot of the
landing page or signup form if all three
of these requirements are met then you
do not need to require consent however
if you do not have explicit consent
provable consent or evidence of
agreement and collection mechanism then
you may need to reacquire prove
full consent as part of this audit
marketers must review all of their
campaign landing pages subscription
forms registration forms and contact
forms review each of these to make sure
that there is an explicit opt-in
mechanism make sure that each opt-in is
separate along with clear terms of what
will be collected how the data will be
used and what the user will receive an
exchange be sure that none of these
sources have bundled opt-in agreements
but that each separate agreement is
clear as such each landing page or data
collection page should also have a link
to your company privacy policy and data
policy for the user to review finally
review your newsletter and all email
communications to ensure that the
company address privacy policy an
unsubscribe link are included in each
and every email then review the
unsubscribe process it should be a one
page single click process the
unsubscribe should happen immediately
this is the advantage of working with an
email service provider as these requests
are handled through their system
processed immediately and the user
record is updated do not ask for
additional information request payment
or have a multi-page process the
unsubscribe process should not be hidden
or obstructed in any way finally this
regulation is a great opportunity for
companies to review and update their
privacy policies first a privacy policy
should be clearly written for people to
understand it should outline the data
that you collect directly such as email
addresses users names and if you collect
page visit data in addition a cookie
policy should be outlined if not already
addressed in a separate document the
privacy policy and the cookie policy
must outline the types of information
collected how it is used if it is shared
and with
it is shared it must also state where
the users data is stored and processed
user rights must also be addressed with
links or instructions to request their
data request to be forgotten and data
portability hi there if you like this
video subscribe to the simple learn
YouTube channel and click here to watch
similar videos de nerd up and get
certified click here